as residents of the district of
rochefort we all have a responsibility
to do whatever is within our power
to prevent all forms of victimization
and genocide
the statement of commitment will be read
by councillor mike
wilkinson we recognised the holocaust
shook the foundations of modern
civilization
its unprecedented character and horror
will always hold
universal meaning we believe the
holocaust must have
a permanent place in our nation's
collective memory
we honor the survivors still with us and
reaffirm
our shared goals of mutual understanding
and justice
we must make sure that future
generations understand the causes
of the holocaust and reflect upon its
consequences
we vow to remember the victims of nazi
persecution
and of all genocide we value the
sacrifices of those who have risked
their lives
to protect or rescue victims as a
touchstone
of the human capacity for good in the
face of evil
we recognize that humanity is still
scarred by the belief
that race religion disability
or sexuality makes people's lives
worth less than others genocide
anti-semitism racism xenophobia and
discrimination still continue
we have shared responsibility to fight
these evils
we pledge to strengthen our efforts to
promote education
and research about the holocaust and
other genocide
we will do our utmost to make sure that
the lessons of such events
are fully learned we will continue to
encourage holocaust remembrance
by commemorating uk holocaust memorial
day
we condemn the evils